All right, Data2100
students, I hope you're ready
to get an introduction to
Structured Query Language.
Structured Query Language,
people call it SQL,
SQL, either way is great.
I refer to it as SQL.
So let's talk about what is SQL
and why does it matter? Why are we
learning it? And then let's dive
into writing some SQL queries. So
first off, we're going to write SQL
queries. We're going to understand
the usage of each of the following
clauses. So select from and
where. I'm also going to tell you
why is this so important to learn.
So as a reminder, Overland is
our database we are going to be
working with. In this class,
oftentimes we'll be using Overland.
There's another one that I'll
introduce you to as well, but
generally we're going to be using
Overland Ski Resort. Now remember,
Overland Peak Resort is one of
the oldest, largest, and most
successful ski resorts in
Pennsylvania. It's also fictional,
But you know what? I love to ski,
love to snowboard, so this is a fun
data set to work with. And you'll
notice that this data set, there's
some things built into it that
really mimic a lot of how a lot of
smaller relational databases look,
that they're not always perfect,
right? That we are dealing with data
that we have to understand exactly
what quality type of data are we
dealing with here. So we'll talk
about data quality as we get into
the database, but it's a great way to
learn SQL, to query the Overland
database and get familiar with it.
All right, so this is what
our Overland ERD looks
like. Now as a pop quiz,
what does ERD stand for?
I hope you said Entity
Relationship Diagram.
Each of these different tables in
this database are different entities.
Again, we can use entity and table
interchangeably, so just keep that
in mind. And we care about the
relationships between the tables,
right? So we're going to be referring
back to this entity relationship
diagram quite often throughout the
course, so just keep that in mind.
When we are retrieving data
from databases, we use SQL.
It stands for Structured
Query Language. It is the
standard for creating,
querying, relational databases.
It kind of uses common language.
It's actually pretty easy to
interpret, and so it's a great
language to start out with learning.
When we use an SQL state, when we
write SQL, we are going to start off
by using an SQL select statement.
There's different types of statements,
but we're going to start out with
a select statement. And an SQL
select statement does one of the
following. We can choose a specific
number of rows to be returned. We
can choose specific requirements that
rows or records must meet to be
returned to us. We can also aggregate
data. We can join different tables
together. We'll talk more about
that. And we can see as many columns
as we want to see or as few columns
as we want to see. so we can really
do this idea of projection which
is choosing the columns in a table
that we want returned to us selection
so we can say you know i only want
to choose certain rows in this
table that are meeting this criteria
we can aggregate data so we can say
hey over the last year show me all
the total sales for this specific
salesperson and then we can also
bring together data from different
tables and join it together so sql
select statements are very powerful
but why do you need to know SQL
why does it matter so you should
learn SQL even if you're not a
developer these days almost everyone has
to work in data in some form or
another like we are all working with
data in some form or another
usually it's through spreadsheets or
databases but if you can learn a
little SQL you can become so much
more powerful in your job when
we every year we send off tons of
interns to all different organizations
and they come back and they say,
we are so grateful that we learned
SQL. It is such the standard
still being used in industry
today. It's going to continue to be
used. So it's awesome that you're
learning this skill in this 2000
level course and we're so excited
to have you learning this skill.
So what does an SQL select
syntax look like? Now
we're going to talk a
lot about syntax in this
class. Syntax is rules
that govern a language.
So syntax of a basic
SQL select statement, it
includes these four,
we call these clauses.
Okay, whoa,
whoa,
all right, there we go. There's a clause.
So I have the select clause, the
from clause, the where clause, and
the order by clause. Each of these
clauses have their own purpose.
So select is our first clause that
we write. and that select clause we
say hey which columns right do
we want to retrieve do we want to
retrieve select first name last name
and age all right we're going to say
then from what table right oh we're
going to say from our guest table
we're going to look at our guests
and then comes in our handy where
clause and our where clause says hey
i'm going to limit the records that
are returned to you so i'm only so
maybe we say you know what we only
want to see guests where their age
is less than 16. So that is the
requirement that is placed on that
query. So all records must meet that
requirement to be returned in my query.
So where clause limits the records
returned to us. And then the order
by clause orders, or if you want
to think about it, it sorts our
output. Select from where and order
by. There are some other clauses that
we'll learn, but we're just going
to start here. I get so excited
teaching this content. I love SQL. It
is so powerful and I love that we
start off basic and then you can get
as advanced as you would like, but
we're starting from the ground up.
All right, so here is my entirety
of the select statement. So I'm
going to ignore group by and
having, those are those other two
clauses we're going to add in a
bit. We're not going to worry about
them for now. We're going to focus
again on select from where and
order by and then our handy semicolon
that we end every query with.
So it's required for every select
statement to have select and from.
Again, select says select what
columns, from says from what
tables, okay? So select first
name and last name from the
guest table. Where says, ooh,
it's a conditional expression.
Now, that kind of sounds
complicated. Basically, it's saying,
hey, these conditions must be
met in order for this row to
be, in order for these rows
to be included in your output.
So it's not too crazy. It's
actually really helpful. So where
and then conditional expression.
And then we have order by,
And then we have order by, and
we say, all right, order by what
column name? So we say order by
first name ascending. Now, we're
not going to focus yet on order
by. We'll introduce where a
little bit in this video, but I
just want you to become familiar
with the select statement. And
for now we're just going to
focus on select, from, where,
and order by. So if you're taking
notes, which I hope you are, go
ahead and write those down. So
select, from, where, and order
by. My order by sorts the output.
All right. So when I want to display
specific fields, I use, right, my
select clause. So I say select last
name, comma, first name from customer.
And you'll notice that I separate
my columns with a comma, and then
I end every query with a semicolon.
So this right here is one SQL query.
I have a select clause, and I have
a from clause. This is going to
show me all the last names and all
the first names of all the customers.
Okay, so where is the data
coming from? That's why this from
is so important. It's saying from
what tables. All right, perfect.
So let's go ahead and how
about we write our first SQL
query. I know you're ready. I'm
ready. Let's get this done. So
I'm going to come over here into
Beekeeper. Now, when we do in
-class assignments and we are
working on in-class assignments,
please, I will provide you with SQL
queries and questions to complete.
When we're in these lecture videos,
please just follow along with me.
I'll be talking through the prompts
that we're working on, and I think
you'll find it to be very beneficial.
So I'm going to go ahead and say,
I'm going to, oh, actually, we
already connected to Beekeeper. Okay,
so make sure you launch Beekeeper
Studio. We've already connected.
If not, go back and watch
the Beekeeper video, but
we've already connected to
our Data 2100 SQL Server
database. I'm going to
go ahead and click this.
Okay, perfect.
Now I'm going to go ahead and
press connect, and perfect, we are
connected. So I want you to look
over here and say, all right,
what different databases do I
have access to? You'll notice
there are some different databases
that you have access to. DBVAC
is one that you're going to use
for some homework assignments.
And DBVAC has these different
entities or tables within it.
Overland is the database that
we're going to be working
with a lot in our in-class
videos, things like that.
So we're going to be working
here in Overland. And
Overland has these seven
different tables. Now, if
I come back here and I
show you our Overland ERD,
right, you are familiar.
Oh,
I'm going to discard that. You are
familiar with the Overland ERD,
okay, our Entity Relationship
Diagram. So we can see here I have a
household table, a guest table,
visit table, and on down. So when I
look at Beekeeper, I can see here,
oh I'm in the Overland database in
the upper left hand corner. So if
you ever need to switch databases,
you just click this drop down menu
and switch to a different database.
So I'm in the Overland database
and I'm going to be working with
say the guest table. So I can click
down on that drop down by guest
and it will show me here are the
different fields in my guest tables.
We can also call them columns.
So I have all these different
columns in my guest table. So I'm
going to go ahead and say select star
from guest. And you're probably
wondering, what in the world, Reagan?
Why did you put, why did you say
star? Because it's an asterisk.
Yes, it is an asterisk, but I
prefer to say select star because I
think it's fun. Okay. So I'm going
to say select star from guest.
I'm going to go ahead and press
run, or you can say control enter.
And this is an entire query.
Now I'm not going to tell
you what this is going to
return, but I want you to
take a look at it. What do
you think it's returning?
So let's take a look at this.
So I'm looking at select
star from guest. I'm going
to take a look at this
output down here below.
And what am I noticing about this output?
First off, what is it returning to
me? So I can see here I have guest
ID, household ID, first name, last
name, gender, age, season pass,
and edu when i take a look at my
overland erd and day dictionary i
can see here that that is returning
my in every single field in my
guest table okay every single field
is being returned to me guest id
household id first name last name
gender age season pass and edu these
are all being returned to me. So
what select star does is select
star says, show me everything from
the guest table. Okay, show me
everything. So when I see a question
that looks like this, show me all
data from the guest table, this
is how I would write the query to
answer that question. I am showing
all data from the guest table. So
that was a moment. We just wrote
our first SQL query and ran it and
now it's showing me all this awesome
data from my guest table, right?
It's so fun because now I can start
to manipulate and say, you know, I
only want to see certain columns.
So say I want to say, you know what,
select first name, last name, and
gender and age from my guest table. So
show me all this data from my guest
table. I'm going to go ahead. I'm
going to say control and enter, or
you can just do run, but I'm going
to say control, enter. And now it shows
me all of my guests. So I'm showing
every record of data and it's showing
me their first name, their last
name, their gender, and their age.
Now, if I throw in here guest ID,
now, as you'll notice here, right,
I'm separating all of these fields
here in my select clause with commas.
I do not have a comma after age.
That will throw an error, okay? So
just between the fields is where I
have the commas. So now when I run
this, I say select guest ID, first
name, last name, gender, and age.
Now, as a pop quiz, what is guest ID?
Guest ID is the primary key, right?
It's our primary key. It uniquely
identifies every guest in my
guest table. So guest ID number
one, their name is Christian
Willis, gender male age 45. So now I
have my whole record of data about
that guest, but I'm only showing
certain columns, right, or fields
about that record of data, okay?
So, so powerful, that is
how we write an SQL query.
So this prompt would read,
show me the guest ID,
first name, last name,
gender,
and age of all guests.
Okay, so that prompt, this
query would answer that prompt.
All right, so fun.
Another question here, I
want you to kind of be aware
of our Beekeeper Studio
and what it looks like, is
what is the total number of
guests in my guest table?
You're probably like, well, Reagan,
I don't want to scroll all the
way down here. You don't have to.
Come down here, and you can see
there's 13,140 records. So I have
13,140 guests in this guest table.
Okay, perfect. Let's come back
here to our PowerPoint deck. So we
can continue to write really awesome
queries with select and from.
They will show me, I can
say the different column
names, from what tables.
But now we're going to throw
in, I want to introduce you
to my handy where clause.
Where is so important in
writing SQL queries. This is
where I say only include
records that meet this criteria.
So let's go ahead and do this.
I'm going to show you
a couple more slides.
All right, so let's look
at the where clause.
So a where clause comes after the
from statement and is used to restrict
the output rows unless they match
the criteria you are looking for.
So for example, I can say select
last name, comma, first name from
customer where their state is equal
to Utah. So that state field then
for the records must equal Utah to
be included in this query's output.
Now, as you'll find in this class,
you'll read content.
I will walk you through content
here in our lecture videos. But
getting the hands-on experience in
writing the queries, that's really
where the learning happens. So
we'll go ahead and write a query
in just one second. We can use
all sorts of different criteria
in our WHERE clause, and we are
using match criteria. So the where
clause match criteria may include
equals, not equal to, greater
than, less than, greater than or
equal to, less than or equal to,
and then we'll also talk about
null values. So we can use any of
these operators to help us in our
where clause. So let's go ahead
and take a look at our where clause
and write a couple of examples.
So I'm going to come down here and I'm
going to say, you know,
show me, let's see,
show all data from the employee
table. Okay, so let's go ahead and
write the, so I want to show all
data from the employee table. So
sometimes you may want to start out
with the from clause. And so you
went from employee because I know
that's where my data is coming
from. and when I show all data,
I'm going to say select star, okay,
from employees. So let's go ahead
and run this. Now when I run
this, it's going to run this
whole query sheet right here.
So it's ran that, it's ran this
query and it's ran this query.
We are going to see the results of
the most bottom, the last query here
that it ran. So I'm showing here
all of the data from my employee
table. I am showing that right here
at the bottom. But if I only want to
run the select star from employee,
then I just highlight this one query
and press run selection. So if I
want to run this select guest ID
for same last name, gender, and age
up here, I would highlight it and
press run selection. But if I'm just
running the last query on the query
sheet that we're dealing with right
here, then there's really no need
to highlight this last query. That's
what's going to appear for you.
But you'll see, I kind of get in
the habit and I do highlight the
query that I want to run. So
again, these are query sheets that
we are working within right here.
So think of this as like a Word
document or just basically a text
file that is allowing us to write
the queries and then we press
the run down here. Okay, perfect.
So select star from employee.
When I do that, I see here that I
have all of the rows and all of
the columns for employee appearing.
Now, what if though I want to
say, show me the first name, last
name, and age for all employees
over 45 okay so let's go ahead and
write this query so I know that I
am going to be pulling data from
the employee table okay and if you
have any questions on where what
the employee table is named you
can come back I've linked the
overland ERD and a dictionary I've
linked it right above this video I
have a file just with it so here
the employee table is just named
employee But we'll notice here
that the employee first name and
last name, these field names are
EMP, F name, EMP, L name. So I
must type them exactly into my SQL
query just like they are listed
there in my entity relationship
diagram. So I can see them down
here, employee first name,
employee last name. So I'm going to
say select employee EMP first
name, EMP last name, and age. Okay.
And for all employees over
45. And so when I run this,
though, initially, let's
just run this to begin with.
My tip is to run your queries often.
I notice, though, that I am
including employees who are younger
than 25. But I only want to include
those for all employees over,
let's say, the age of 45. It
will be a little bit more formal.
So I'm going to then, here
I'm going to place my cursor
right in front of that
semicolon. And I'm going to say
from employee, and I'll say
where age is greater than 45.
Okay, so they must be over
the age of 45 to be included
in my output. So I'm going
to go ahead and run this.
And now when I do down here, what I
see is that all of my employees who
are over the age of 45 are appearing
in my output. So they must be over
the age of 45. So I can see here
that Skylar Patrick is my employee
and they are over the age of 45. So
I can double check that my query is
returning what it should. We'll
notice here that result three,
again, because we have three different
queries running here, results
in 172 rows. So I have 172 employees
who are over the age of 45.
So that is just one example of what
you can do with the where clause.
You can also do things like maybe
I only want to return employees.
So I'll say, you know what, show
me all employees who have the last
name of Johnson. I'm looking right
here at Cohen Johnson. So I'm
going to come down here. I'm going
to do the same thing here. When
I say show me all employees, maybe
I mean first name, last name.
And so I'll say select employee
first name, employee last last name,
uh, from employee.
And then I'll say from employee.
And then I'll say, sometimes it wants
to do that. It will run just fine.
Um,
where,
uh,
let's say last employee, last name
is equal to, and then I'm going to
say Johnson. Now, why did I, why did
I do single quotation marks around
Johnson. Okay, why did I do this?
Well, this is because if I'm dealing
with qualitative data, so things
like text, for example, like Johnson,
it's not a number. I must put
single quotations around it in order
for it to run correctly. So just keep
that in mind that if I it equal to
employee last name equal to johnson
and i run this query there was a
problem that's what my that's my
query outputs to me so if i zoom out
a little bit let's see invalid column
name johnson okay so it wants to
treat it like a column name so pay
attention to your errors and we are
going to include text data qualitative
type of data we'll talk more about
what that means but just for now
think of it as a lot of text data.
We are going to include text data
inside of single quotation marks.
All right so now when
I go ahead and run this
you can see here that I have all of the
employees last names that are Johnson.
All those employees are
returning to me. So I have eight
employees who have the last name
Johnson. So the where clause
is setting the requirement that
the last name must be equal
to Johnson in order to be
included in this query's output.
So powerful, right?
SQL is extremely powerful.
So now let's come over here.
And the last thing that I want,
or just two more things I want
to talk to you about. Number
one is sometimes we want to
do multiple matching criteria,
saying this must be true
and this must be true.
Or we might say this must be true
or this must be true. Okay, so
we'll do an example. of that. Let's
go ahead and do that over here.
So let's say that I want to
say where employee's last name
equal to Johnson or employee
last name equal to Smith. Okay.
Maybe I want to say your last name
either has to be Johnson or Smith
to be included in this query's
output. When I run this then I see
that I have employees with the
last name of Johnson or Smith being
included in my output. Now, why
couldn't I do and here? Okay. Why
couldn't I do and? The reason I
couldn't do and is because somebody's
last name is not Johnson and
Smith, according to my data, right?
Because they have one piece of,
they have one last name here listed.
So that would be employee
last name equal to
Johnson or employee last
name equal to Smith. Okay,
so I just want you to keep
that in mind. You will
notice that we capitalize
all of our clauses.
Okay, that SQL is not case
sensitive, but for best practice,
we are going to capitalize
all clauses. We are also going
to capitalize our match
operators here like and and or.
And then we do capitalize
based upon how the columns are
capitalized, if you will,
here in our database. So just
keep that in mind. The big
ones to keep in mind are select
from where group I having,
and then our ands and our ors.
You will notice that
here I had to rename,
I said or employee last
name equal to Smith.
You might have wondered why I
couldn't just say employee last name
equal to Johnson or Smith. And the
reason is this or basically says,
all right, something to do with
Smith. It's not looking at employee
last name anymore. So we must restate
the column that we are looking for
Smith within, okay? So that's just
something to keep in mind here.
One other thing we could do
here is we could say employee
last name equal to Johnson
and their age greater than 20.
So that could be two requirements
that I set for employees.
So let's go ahead and run this last one.
And when I do this, you can
see that these employees'
last names are Johnson,
and they are older than 20.
So this query would then
answer the prompt, we have
the last name of Johnson
and are older than 20.
Keep in mind here, these dashes,
right? These dashes are comments, so
these comments are basically the
processor is going to ignore these,
and these can just be comments that
we write to ourselves or that we copy
in prompts. So here's a good
introduction to SQL. We will do a lot
more SQL, but I just wanted to give
you an introduction and have you
start writing queries. But I encourage
you, take three minutes, write a
couple more queries, and see what
questions you can answer. Take care.